i've analyzed dozens of startups on this
channel and they all have one thing in
common growth comes in six distinct
phases it doesn't matter if we're
talking about a massive multinational
tech company like google or a tiny
startup with nothing more than an idea
they all fit perfectly into this simple
growth framework if you can progress
through all six of these levels you'll
wind up running a massive company with a
soaring stock price but these aren't
easy steps and i should know i've been
an entrepreneur for the last decade and
i'm still stuck on level four very few
companies have what it takes to really
go the distance and knock down all six
milestones but when they do they
inevitably wind up becoming worth
hundreds of billions of dollars in the
process it doesn't matter if you're
still just coming up with your very
first business idea or running a startup
worth billions you need to have good
answers for how you're gonna get through
each of these stages if you want to grow
your business so let's walk through the
entire entrepreneurial journey from idea
to ipo and beyond
level one should be the easiest part but
a surprising amount of entrepreneurs
fall short here they come up with an
idea but they can't build a real product
and until you have a product you really
can't move on to the later stages well
some companies try to move forward
without building a real product but they
always fail there's even a term for fake
products like this vaporware you don't
want to wind up working on a vaporware
project it never ends well just look at
theranos elizabeth homes was able to
attract investors employees and even
customers but she couldn't deliver a
functioning product so the company
crashed and burned
so when you're starting out you need to
have a clear vision for your product and
what skills will be required to actually
get it built if you want to build the
next great social network you'll
probably need some talented software
developers on your team ideally you'd be
a solid programmer yourself just look at
the founding teams behind every
successful social network there's always
at least one computer scientist on board
from the earliest stage now it is
possible to build a technology company
with only a business background but the
deck is going to be stacked against you
in a few key ways first off investors
are well aware that technical teams tend
to win so they will be less likely to
fund you and second developers don't
like working for non-technical people
it's really hard to get motivated to
work for someone who has no clue what
you actually do great technical minds
don't want to work with someone who will
just tell them to make the website fast
they want to partner with someone who
really understands the challenges of
building high performance software now
the good news is that it's pretty easy
to learn to code these days so even if
you have a business background you
should be able to study up and learn the
basics in a few months and if you're
building a piece of software i promise
it will be a great investment but what
if your company isn't primarily focused
on software development well then you
probably don't need to learn to code but
you still need to make sure your
founding team has the skills required to
deliver a high quality product clearly
software development wasn't an issue for
theranos what they needed was some sort
of major breakthrough in biology and
microfluidics most people agree that
we're still decades away from this type
of technology but when it arrives you
can be sure that the team that figures
it out will have deep technical
expertise in how biological systems work
so you've made sure that the world
actually needs your product that it's
possible to build your product and that
you have the team with the skills to
deliver that product now what well you
need to answer the level 2 question do
people want to buy your product
tons of talented entrepreneurs will
spend months building the next great
product only to launch it and get zero
sign ups on their landing page avoid
this situation at all costs it's
demoralizing and a huge waste of time
the faster you can get your product
built the faster you can get in the
hands of real users and start getting
feedback that's a big part of why it's
so important to have the technical
skills to build your product directly
within the founding team outsourcing
product development will slow you down
and add an extra layer of complexity to
your product iteration cycles you want
to be able to add a new feature to your
product and then go get feedback from
your users immediately and as soon as
your users give you their opinions you
need to incorporate that into the next
release immediately so how can you
conclusively prove that people want to
buy your product well you can ask them
to pay for it lots of entrepreneurs
start by asking friends family and
professional connections to test new
products it can be hard to get honest
feedback from people you know though so
this is where broader test marketing can
be helpful sharing a demo of what you're
building to popular sites like hacker
news reddit or product hunt can be a
great way to start testing your product
with people you don't know it's
important to understand the difference
between a user and a customer since they
aren't always the same person for
example facebook is a free service to
users the customers are advertisers who
want to reach those specific users if
you're building a business where the
user and the customer are different it
will be very important to validate that
everyone likes what you're building
after all there are tons of websites out
there with lots of users who can't
attract advertisers because they feature
objectionable content i've spent months
building projects i thought would be
successful only to launch them and
completely flop some companies spend
years making this mistake though the
short form video app quibby was in
development for years before going live
on the app store even though they had
spent over a billion dollars developing
the platform and content no one wanted
to pay for it the quibby team offered a
free trial but pretty much everyone who
tried the app wound up cancelling as
soon as the trial ended it was a
disappointing outcome for everyone
involved and it highlighted the
importance of validating demand for your
product so build your product quickly
adding only the few features you need to
prove the concept and then get it in the
hands of real customers as soon as you
have clear evidence that customers are
willing to pay for your product you'll
have a much easier time raising money
hiring employees and scaling your
business but getting customers to pay
for your product is only half the battle
plenty of entrepreneurs build a product
and establish a customer base only to
run head first into the level three
milestone profitability the entire point
of any business is to generate a profit
but a shocking amount of companies never
figure out how to do it now to be fair
i'm really talking about gross profit
here which is just revenue minus costs
it's completely normal for high growth
companies not to make net profits for
years but that's a completely different
metric let me explain gross profit
describes how much money a business
makes from just delivering their product
to customers it's just how much money
the customer pays minus how much it
costs to produce that particular product
for software companies gross profits are
typically very high since servers don't
cost very much to run but the gross
profits of grocery stores are usually
extremely low since the food they sell
to customers is expensive so you need to
really investigate how much your product
costs since this will be a critical
factor in determining if you can make a
positive gross profit selling your
product this might seem obvious but
you'd be surprised at how many startups
get this wrong they assume that they can
undercut the competition and then
magically reduce their costs in the long
term sometimes there really is a path to
reduce costs through automation or scale
economies your startup might be paying a
lot right now but you might be able to
swap in robots down the line or build a
larger manufacturing plant that can
produce products very cheaply it does
happen but often the business model is
just fundamentally flawed and there's no
path towards profitability just look at
what happened to moviepass the idea was
simple get people to pay for a
subscription and then let them go see
unlimited movies in theaters whenever
they want people loved moviepass the
product worked perfectly and customers
were definitely willing to pay the
monthly subscription fee so moviepass
had cleared the first two hurdles but
getting to gross profitability was
another issue entirely see every time a
moviepass customer swiped their
membership card at a theater moviepass
would have to pay for the ticket and
moviepass customers loved watching
movies the hope was that theaters would
be willing to charge lower prices or
maybe moviepass customers wouldn't see
so many movies but that never happened
instead the cost of each moviepass
customer exceeded the revenue they were
bringing in so the company was never
able to generate a gross profit it was a
tough situation for moviepass and the
company eventually had to file for
bankruptcy since they just couldn't find
a profitable business model even though
they had built a product that customers
loved none of that mattered since they
were losing so much money so always be
honest with yourself and your investors
is there really a path to making
reliable gross profits any company can
attract customers by selling something
at an unsustainably low price but if
they can't turn things around quickly
bankruptcy is inevitable but let's
assume that you found a profitable
business every customer you bring in
generates more revenue than cost and
you're in a good financial position well
now you have a new problem how can you
grow your business
you might have a few customers coming in
organically but very few companies wind
up growing organically forever
eventually every company builds a sales
and marketing organization even though
you might not see a lot of marketing for
products like google search there's
still a large organization dedicated to
getting advertisers to pay for google
ads building a profitable marketing
machine is key to advancing past level
four and this is one of the trickiest
things to do at scale when you get to
this stage two terms will start to rule
your life lifetime value and customer
acquisition cost lifetime value or ltv
is the total amount of gross profit
generated by a customer basically it's
just how much profit you actually take
home from the average customer now a big
ticket item like a fancy car might
generate thousands of dollars in
lifetime value almost immediately on the
flip side a free to play game might only
generate a few dollars of ltv with most
of it coming from a small portion of the
user base remember ltv is an average
figure so some companies will have tons
of customers using a product for free
and then make most of their profits from
just a few big whales regardless this
lifetime value figure determines how
much you can spend to acquire a new
customer if your ltv is 100
then paying a customer acquisition cost
or cac of less than 100
will mean that you're growing profitably
and this is where it gets really tricky
see finding new customers isn't always
easy you might need to test out several
different marketing channels before you
find one that really works effectively
and then even after you're running ads
and getting customers to buy you need to
make sure that your customer acquisition
costs stay lower than your lifetime
value as you scale and this is where a
lot of businesses run into trouble
they've built a product that people are
willing to buy at a profitable price but
they just can't find scalable marketing
channels plenty of young businesses will
start running ads on facebook and see
good results for the first few months
but then slowly as they start spending
more and more money the customer
acquisition costs start to rise
eventually that marketing channel isn't
profitable anymore and the startup needs
to find a new way to reach customers it
can lead to a really tough situation
like what happened with blue apron
shortly after they went public even
though their meal delivery kit business
had grown significantly they just
couldn't acquire new customers cheaply
enough to keep growing part of the
problem was that customers wouldn't
stick around long enough to generate a
high lifetime value shipping food is
expensive so it's not like blue apron
was making big profits on every box they
shipped the margins are thin now slim
margins aren't that big of a deal if the
customers are sticking around for a long
time but that just wasn't happening when
customers stopped ordering after just
one or two months the lifetime value
would drop meaning that the marketing
team couldn't spend as much to acquire
new customers so the reason that you see
so many youtube ads for vpns is that
those companies have lifetime values
that are high enough to pay for tons of
ads if you sign up for a vpn you're very
likely to just keep using it for years
and it doesn't cost a lot to provide
that service unlike shipping a box of
food all the vpn company needs to do is
keep a server online building a
profitable marketing engine is hard but
not impossible i've been able to get
past level 4 twice in my entrepreneurial
career and it's unlocked millions of
dollars in revenue every time we crack
the code but i've never been able to
break through to level five
see once you have a growing business
everything starts revolving around scale
how big is the market that you're going
after and how quickly can you capture it
and this is where the really big growth
stage investors start getting involved
when you're just working on building a
product you might be able to raise a
million dollars in seed money once you
have paying customers and a viable
marketing strategy you might be able to
raise 10 million in venture funding but
everything changes once you can prove
that bigger investments will lead to
higher returns for investors a big
problem for many companies is running
out of places to invest profitably they
develop one great product figure out the
marketing plan and then start growing
really quickly but over time they start
saturating the market and need to find
new opportunities if a company can find
good uses of capital they can keep
growing but if they can't they'll
quickly stall out for example in 2012
facebook bought instagram for one
billion dollars they just made 26
billion dollars from instagram last year
that's an incredible return on
investment and it's something that
larger companies need to get really good
at if they want to be around for the
long term on the flip side it can be
useful to look at peloton in 2020 the
stock started climbing quickly as people
ordered more and more exercise bikes
peloton was perfectly positioned to take
advantage of the new trend of working
out at home but they ran into a problem
basically everyone who was going to buy
a peloton bought one in 2020 they had
delivered a great product found a good
price point for it and professionalized
their marketing efforts but they hit a
ceiling it's always a bit silly to say i
could have done it better but i do think
they could have avoided this situation
by acquiring some of the other fitness
brands while their stock was so highly
valued strava could have helped them
expand to outdoor fitness whoop would
have enabled better health monitoring
tonal would let them offer strength
training and hydros rowing machine seems
like a logical extension from stationary
bikes all of those companies are worth
less than eight billion dollars in total
meanwhile peloton was worth 60 billion
at its peak it's hard to say if that
strategy would have worked out for them
but peloton has fallen in value to just
eight billion dollars today so clearly
shareholders aren't optimistic about
them scaling any further when you're a
public company you need to be able to
consistently find new areas for growth
it's an incredibly challenging task but
that's why these companies are worth
billions but there's an entirely
separate class of companies that are
essentially untouchable they are the
mega corporations that have achieved
startup nirvana and broken through the
sixth and final hurdle of business
success they've created a platform
every startup loves to say that they're
building a platform it's a super trendy
buzzword and to be fair some
entrepreneurs really are building
platforms but these things take time to
actually develop microsoft is the
classic example of a platform business
and bill gates has outlined exactly how
he thinks about building platforms bill
says that you're only really a platform
if the value of the ecosystem on top of
the platform is larger than the company
that owns the platform what that means
in practice is that you're enabling
entirely new businesses to develop on
top of what you've built and if you add
up all the value that those businesses
create it's larger than the underlying
company that's certainly true for
microsoft windows which has enabled
entire industries to flourish everything
from accounting software to video games
is built on top of windows but microsoft
isn't the only platform company out
there every major tech company has
figured out a way to conquer level 6 and
become a platform apple has the iphone
and mac platform amazon has built a
platform for independent merchants and
tons of businesses have been built on
top of google search google apps and
even youtube so regardless of where you
are in these six stages of business
growth just stay focused on getting to
the next level and if you'd like to
learn about how shopify grew from a tiny
snowboarding website into a
multi-billion dollar e-commerce platform
just watch this video next thanks for
watching